crispy phyllo delicious with a simple
honey yogurt
now
these are beautiful
Fila pastry sheets now it is possible to
make it
but to be honest to try and stretch
the pastry that thin and get it even
it's an absolute nightmare Life's too
short to make it at home when you can
buy amazing phyllo pastry
so
when working with it always get a nice
damp cloth
and just lay
the damp cloth over it that keeps it
nice and moist and it stops
the filo pastry from actually drying out
put a pan on to melt your butter
it's the butter that gives the
crispiness
to the filo pastry
have you ever got a brush or coat
feel a pastry with butter and make sure
that butter is nicely seasoned you take
your first layer layer onto the balls
nice brush that with your butter
and the nice thing about filo pastry is
that it can be used for Savory and sweet
these are going to have a fragrance
Savory flavor with thyme black pepper
and parmesan cheese so no need for salt
lift up the corner
and fold very quickly brush the ends
and just
nip
those ends together
non-stick pan on a little splash of
olive oil fry the pastry for one to two
minutes on each side
so you want them to sort of puff up
the secrets get them quickly you can
smell that cheese in that time you're
looking for them to become golden and
crispy simple as that and then out
smells delicious
and as they sit and cool down instantly
they become really nice and crispy
the filo goes fantastically well with
thick creamy Greek yogurt and a drizzle
of runny honey
and there's something quite sort of
Middle East and about the herb the
yogurt and the honey and the sort of
crispy textures of the filo pastry an
alternative savory breakfast
when you want a stunning and
sophisticated breakfast that mixes
fragrant herbs and cheese with glorious
honey yogurt this Middle Eastern treat
hits the spot and it's so simple to make
gorgeous grilled lamb copters with my
incredible Twist on the Middle Eastern
classic hummus
first job glorious beetroot hummus
I'm gonna blend and puree the cooked
chickpea and the beetroot now the
beetroot gives that pickly delicious
flavor to the hummus beetroots in
with the chickpea
a nice seasoning of salt and pepper
a tablespoon of olive oil a tablespoon
of tahini this is roasted sesame seeds
pounded and mixed with oil
crushed garlic and toasted cumin seeds
grind then pop into a blender
[Music]
I love that nice dark Rich color and you
finish it
with a nice lemon
slice it in half
take out the seeds
and squeeze the fresh lemon juice at the
end just wakes up the acidity in the
beetroot but really cuts the richness of
the chickpea and the lemon juice is
pivotal it really brings the beetroot
and the chickpeas together chickpeas are
packed with protein very dense and it
needs that kind of acidity one more
little blend
lovely
nice little taste
that's delicious homemade beetroot
hummus so tasty and it really is that
easy to make to finish some toasted
cumin seeds and sumac
that is delicious it's a sort of Middle
Eastern spice
and then
some sesame seeds
finish that off
with margarine almost done now for my
copters panel onion
nice and finely diced
garlic three nice clothes
squeeze the garlic
over the onions onions
garlic in
you get a really nice color on them
after that
a nice teaspoon of chili flakes
beautiful now into our pestle and mortar
with a teaspoon of toasted cumin give
that a little bit of salt in there helps
grind it down that is such a lovely
smell
aromatic
exciting spicy intriguing
once ground to a fine powder sprinkle
your spices into the onion and garlic to
create a wonderful aromatic paste now
for the lamb mints
lightly season it
and then add all that wonderful flavor
next for some freshness parsley and mint
roughly chopped and a glug of olive oil
put your hands in there
and give that a really good mix
traditionally you can see
koftas on little sticks barbecue skewers
and depending Where You Are
they have different sort of variations
and shapes and sizes I much prefer the
nice little sort of
almost like little mini
Burgers like little mini sliders
but these can be griddled
these can be fried in a pan or even
cooked on the barbecue
start by Rolling the mix into a golf
pool size then flatten out always
lightly oil
your plate
that way when you set them in the fridge
don't need to be all again they're just
going straight into the pan because
they've got oil underneath and all on
top keep your hands lightly oiled
and it helps
stop the lamb from sticking to your
fingers then pop them into the fridge to
set and firm up before cooking
now you can cook the kofta in a frying
pan on the barbecue or an amazing little
griddle pan
gets the plaque really nice and hot
whilst that heats I'm making a yogurt
dip I love a nice sort of fresh minted
yogurt
put fresh mint leaves salt and a pinch
of toasted cumin and black pepper into a
pestle and mortar to grind as you start
to sort of
blend
the mint almost turns into a nice fresh
mint puree and smell out of that
it's incredible
add yogurt and I like Greek best and a
squeeze of lemon
look at that now
beautiful now the copter so they go on
[Music]
one of the biggest problems on cooking
copper is that they move them too early
and they start to break up but let them
Grill and by grilling them they'll
naturally lift off the bar once they're
charcoaled and so literally two two and
a half minutes each side
now
turn it over
beautiful
smell is incredible
once browned on both sides they're ready
to serve
on
[Music]
delicious I absolutely love lunches like
this because it's sort of bold food
that's packed full of freshness and
great flavors these quick and easy minty
lamb koftas serve with beetroot hummus
are perfect for a relaxed meal your
family and friends will all want to tuck
into
foreign